tu te fous de moi rigaud a oubliés
livrée que je peux pas vivre et plus que
ce que je lis lancement oui cours
mon chef est tellement contentes de non
ces bateaux de vous parler mon amour
j'aurais jamais dans ça peut pas faire
de bon goût du jour j'aurai
bonjour monsieur costard m chassaigne
ont chanté de 1988 à 1990 vous avez fait
693 don de sperme sous le nom de frenzy
vous est le géniteur de 533 enfants dont
142 elle connaît de votre identité
tu sais que c'est le rêve de tout avocat
de codina faire aussi significative 5
milliards d'êtres humains vont se
demander qui est sous fonzii on est tous
frères
c'est quoi le profil de chacun des
enfants papa comment une personne
normale se sentir de cette situation une
personne normale ne serait pas dans
cette situation
comme mais les amis j'aimerais avoir la
vérité sur mes origines je peux pas
devenir le père de 533 enfants c'est
impossible
oui je peux leur ange gardien ben mon
métier de [ __ ] voilà tout excusez moi
pardon circulait
ah ah
tu cherches à te faire démasquer on
pourrait plaider l'aliénation mentale je
n'ai pas de problème d'aliénation
mentale comment sera devant le juge dit
le exactement comme ça
c'est la première fois de ma vie que
j'ai l'impression d'être sur la bonne
route
c'est quoi ça j'ai pris un comique pour
m'aider